llegamos a las noticias económicas de la
mano de Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida de regreso Muchas gracias
empecemos con las noticias de nuestra
región particularmente en Argentina el
gobierno de Alberto Fernández está
tomando medidas para combatir la
altísima inflación una inflación María
clara que ya se asoma al ciento nueve
por ciento anual rebasando cualquier
expectativa del mercado que de por sí ya
es bastante pesimista siempre el
gobierno anunció entonces medidas como
el alza en la tasa de interés que a
partir de este lunes se ubicará en el
97% anual apenas dos semanas después de
haberla subido del 81 al 91%. El Banco
Central también aumentará la
intervención en el mercado cambiario y
El Ejecutivo dijo que buscará acelerar
Los acuerdos con el fondo monetario
internacional y también el uso del Joan
en chino en lugar de dólares esto para
frenar ese descenso prolongado en el
valor de la moneda local se anunció
también en el mercado Central de
Argentina va a tener un nuevo rol que le
va a permitir importar directamente
productos sin aranceles esto para
venderlos en los comercios y así
atemplar las salsas y los precios de los
alimentos la inflación también preocupa
en Europa pero allí la comisión europea
tiene mejores noticias frente a la
perspectiva de este año pues El
Ejecutivo de la Unión Europea ve hoy que
el crecimiento económico de la zona
Europa va a ser mejor de lo que esperaba
en febrero pasado Aunque muy poco y
también el verdadero problema va a
seguir siendo sin duda la inflación como
lo explica a continuación nuestra
corresponsal en Bruselas Esther Herrera
buenas noticias para la economía europea
Bruselas ha confirmado con sus
previsiones económicas lo que se parecía
atisbar este mismo año y es que la
eurozona será capaz de esquivar la
recesión este año según las previsiones
de la comisión europea la eurozona
crecerá un 1,1% este año entre las
economías que más van a crecer está
España con un 1,9% seguida de Países
Bajos Francia e Italia pero sin embargo
Alemania motor de la economía europea
sin embargo mantiene una previsión de
crecimiento de un exiguo 0,2% sobre todo
la principal razón que explica esta
aceleración de la economía en la
eurozona está la bajada de los precios
de la energía y luego una mejora en el
mercado laboral que ha abatido
Auténticos récords en los últimos meses
en la Unión Europea sin embargo no todos
son buenas noticias porque la inflación
sigue siendo muy alta a pesar de la
bajada de los precios de la energía lo
que preocupa especialmente es la
inflación subyacente es decir la que no
tiene en cuenta ni los alimentos frescos
ni la energía esta seguirá muy alta
según las previsiones superará el 6%
esto afectará notablemente al poder
adquisitivo de los hogares pero también
se traduce en un alza de los tipos de
interés para tratar de reducir la
inflación en un 2% tal y como advirtió
recientemente El Banco Central europeo
Daniela la noticia en Estados Unidos es
que se van a volver a reanudar las
negociaciones por el techo de la deuda y
lo harán Este martes será una reunión
entre el presidente Joe biden y los
líderes del Congreso de la república Y
lo que van a hacer es conversar sobre el
techo de la deuda con la esperanza de
encontrar un terreno común sobre los
niveles de gasto para evitar un
incumplimiento a partir del primero de
junio Aunque del más reciente encuentro
no pareció surgir alguna base
significativo
la Casa Blanca Esta vez sí es un poco
más optimista
mira lo que aprendí hace mucho tiempo y
lo sabes bien como yo es que nunca es
bueno caracterizar una negociación en
medio de una negociación sigo siendo
optimista porque soy un optimista
congénito pero realmente creo que hay un
deseo tanto de su parte como de la
nuestra de llegar a un acuerdo Creo que
seremos capaces de hacerlo
Cuáles son los indicadores de este lunes
pues tras el resultado electoral del
domingo en el que ya se sabe que habrá
una segunda vuelta en Turquía la moneda
de ese país se mantuvo relativamente
estable sobre las 19 liras por dólar
Aunque Sí sigue en mínimos de dos meses
vamos a ver cómo el valor del dólar sea
multiplicado por 9 en la última década
en Turquía eso significa que la moneda
local ha perdido casi el 95% de su valor
en este lapso entre tanto principal
índice de la bolsa de Estambul que había
dos por ciento después de haber bajado
más del 6% en las primeras operaciones
Mientras que el principal índice
bancario se desplomaba un 9% antes del
cierre todo muy pendiente de las
elecciones en Europa las bolsas este
lunes operan mixtas en medio del aumento
de las previsiones de crecimiento de la
eurozona de lo que estábamos hablando
bueno Daniela Muchas gracias por todos
los datos económicos del día nos vemos
acá mañana